the great Jim Jackson joining us on the
program are you football fan Jim you
know it still is baby really nice grew
up the Steelers way yeah but didn't you
grow up in Ohio exactly who is your
favorite player last one oh okay
did you play football no not yeah I did
and I separate different surveillance
idea
were you like Ron like remembered LeBron
played wide receiver in high school yeah
I was I played more Italian but that was
that was in my neighborhood I mean
that's what we did either before or you
know grade school we went around to
different neighborhoods who played
because no neighborhood in the snow
during the summer it didn't I mean
football was just now we play bass a
little get me wrong but it was something
about football I don't know I don't know
what it was at that time it was just the
thing to do well in Ohio it is it's in
plus where where you're from you know
football is king up there a couple of
things basketball wise here let me start
with the Rockets with this small ball I
don't know what it means for the regular
season and certainly for the postseason
for this team you can be a matchup
nightmare when you're going you know
night in and night out for a different
city and a different team I get you in a
seven-game series now all of a sudden
it's different because I put all my
efforts into stopping you so Rockets
regular-season Rockets postseason what
do you think is gonna play out here for
them Dan you know that's a good question
and I'm gonna go back and I'm gonna say
this back in 95 96 when I was with the
Mavericks dick Motta was a coach we
employed the same kind of strategy we
had Popeye Jones playing the five it was
like George McCloud myself Jamal was
hurt Mashburn
it was Tony Dumas Jason Kidd and we did
we had to do it by necessity because we
didn't have any faith man so we went on
this rampage we just ran basically three
guards and two fours and just shot a
bunch of threes and back then it was a
little bit different because the
emphasis
you know putting the ball in the post
but when we were hitting threes were
hitting threes it worked okay and then
teams had to try to match up with us and
we figured out our three inside out with
you too but it was a challenge because
we just were wasn't accustomed to
playing like that in certain matchups it
just didn't benefit us very much similar
like this Houston team did in the
regular season against the Lakers the
Lakers didn't want to adjust they want
the play big so it benefited you know
the Rockets but in the last you know two
games against Utah and against Phoenix
when you got perimeter players that can
you know still stress the floor play a
little bit more defense it causes a
little bit more of a challenge for the
Rockets and in the seven-game series
depending on who you're playing if they
have perimeter threats just as much as
the Rockets it's going to be a challenge
I mean because here's the thing I was
looking at some stats right the Rockets
are scoring their opponents outs for the
opponents like 160 to 140 I think it is
in the post I mean in the paint which is
great but they don't get the stops when
they need it yeah and that's been the
overall question and issue with the
Rockets we all know they can score but
in the playoffs in a critical situation
can you get to three stops in a role to
allow your auction to work for it and
that's my biggest thing about Bob the
Rockets you know they're going to give
up some rebounds yeah but they don't
play defense good enough I think in a
playoff to be able to advance your
conference championship even a
championship because of that talking to
Jim Jackson NBA on TNT Tuesday night
analyst he's got Celtics Rockets coming
up tonight also the Clippers and the
76ers at what point do you think the
76ers have to make a decision on are
they a Ben Simmons led team or Joelle
embiid led team that's a great question
because when does management really make
the decision to say you know this is not
going to work
that's the question some some teams do
it a little bit quicker than others
but because the franchise went all in on
both players it's a lot a bit more
challenging for them to have to pick and
choose but they're gonna have to make it
because right now it's just not working
I mean especially with Al Horford came
out and said about some stuff going on
in the locker room he kind of fell back
is it but we're going to keep it at
house but that something is going on it
you know a lot of blend got put on Jimmy
Butler about sayings himself but it's
ironic that when Butler left Minnesota
it was issues that he talked about when
he left Philly with these two and what's
going on it was issues whether that's
you know the two superstar kids not
getting along with Brett brown they're
not getting along with themselves it's
something going on deeper because
there's a reason why this team hasn't
you know gotten better because of the
talent and you know the decision to
stand are we going with the hybrid point
guard where you know he could do
multiple things we can't shoot the
basketball or dominate post player who
pick and pop even though the game is
revolving around perimeter players
that's the biggest question for Philly
who is going to be our guy in the future
you know okay
where we going to go and that's
something from an analytics perspective
you know they try to look at but it's a
tough decision but I think I think if
anything they are heads towards Jim B
but the problem with them being is you
know is his durability if you don't put
your franchise behind in B you would
have to put a mandate on him about
getting in better shape and really being
more professional about what about is
this and that's going to be a tough ass
how surprised where your the Lakers
didn't do anything at the trade deadline
you know I was surprised from the
perspective you know they didn't want to
really give up Kuzma at this time to get
you know what they don't really have a
lot of draft assets so it had to be more
given up key assets or what they want do
I think the biggest issue is
to figure out another playmaker Rondo's
you know played well last night but on a
consistent basis for the Lakers I think
the really catapult and get past the
Clippers Altima if they had to play them
you name me somebody else when a Bron X
is a game and everybody talks about it
the production and play making goes down
but who was out there that can kind of
give them that without giving up you
know Kuzma I think what they may fall
back on it to buy all market maybe and
look at some guys that are available
that can show up that second unit a
little bit more whether that's a wing
player or another point guard so I
wasn't overly surprised because I knew
that they covered it now Kuzma much more
because Big D still has the potential to
be you know a dynamic third option you
know coming in off the bench so we'll
see what happens in the next month with
you guys being born out and see if the
breakers make any moves you played for
12 teams in the NBA you said right
that's right do you have all the jerseys
from all 12 teams and can you name the
12 teams in order
well of course do they all pay checks
I'd know the name okay no the name now a
jersey I don't have Damon Stoudamire
still has my Portland Jersey and he you
know he still has and here's a synthesis
so I got an issue with that
that's my god but that's the only one I
really under teams here maverick terms
you got that right got those two no you
Ellie
you had Toronto in there no no nervous
no no I said Portland Porter has my he
just got played with that was a minute
let me run down okay okay here we go
Mavericks Jersey Philly
Golden State then I went to from Golden
State I went to Portland
then to Atlanta to Cleveland to Miami
Sacramento Houston Phoenix LA now port
number than 98 99 so that lockout year I
think he left out the nets
I said it knows Jersey the second team
okay all right okay all right it's good
job I got all them so I asked some great
cities man i'ma take the beauty of it
though I'm see its beauty over there it
says you're the player you don't
envision yourself you know traveling and
being on different teams and after my
injury my third year that kind of set my
career back but you know it is what it
is but I got an awesome opportunity to
see some great cities pray for some
great franchises and more importantly
meet a lot of great people on and off
the court so things that I do now having
that kind of career passive has opened
it up to be able to have those
friendships you know those connections
that I never would have had but have
chosen that path myself of course now
you know but sometimes in life things
happen and you've got a role which
purchase you know only can we call
Portland can we call Damon Stoudamire
and least get Jim Vallance in his Jersey
by for sure okay Todd see when you get
ahold of my I'm on the case you get his
jersey back yeah I mean he should I mean
you only played like nine games for
Portland yeah play a little bit more a
little bit more okay videos my jersey
nine-nine starts why I got you nine
starts with Portland
yeah nice but I played a lot of minutes
[Laughter]
that was the first time Micra got to the
playoff when that year and we lost you
we lost you San Antonio in the Western
Conference final that year and they went
on to win their first championship with
top of its a year against the Knicks
I didn't mean to besmirch your Portland
career there Jimmy I'm sorry buddy
okay I'm sorry about that hey but I'll
make up for by talking about how great
you were at Ohio State how's that I will
we're gonna work on that today all right
Thank You Jimmy good to talk to you
again all right
that's Jim Jackson TNT got the game too
rockets in the Celtics and you got 76ers
and the Clippers four more Dan Patrick
show tune in to audience Channel 239 on
DirecTV stream for free on BR live or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]